merci beaucoup le nord mais ce nord la
balle sa ville le nom wii où il fait
froid le nord en haut du club là bas nan
mais non mais non c'est pas c'est pas de
ça dont je vais vous parler aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt plutôt sonore là-haut que
que vous cherchez vous avez vous le
chercher en permanence vous savez pas
d'où il vient
qui est-ce qui vous la donner comment il
est là pourquoi il est là je suis sûr qu
ici il y en a qui doivent peut-être se
poser cette question
en tout cas moi alors je vais pas vous
dire que j'ai une science exacte que
j'ai la réponse à la question non non
loin de la voie
ce serait pas du tout en plus j'ai du
mal à croire en les sciences exactes on
est bien là moi je suis super xiii est
un petit moment de flottement mais vous
sonore en fait en fin de compte il vient
d'un endroit assez incroyable en fait
c'est les expériences des expériences
que vous avez les expériences humaines
les expériences amoureuses les amis des
amis oui les amis les amis c'est très
important
alors là il y en a qui sont en train de
se dire d'autre il parle des liens
familiaux avec son texte
non non non pas du tout les amis c'est
très intéressant parce que figurez vous
que si je suis là aujourd'hui c'est
grâce à une personne en tout cas en
grande partie grâce à elle qui est dans
cette salle c'est camille camille je ne
sais pas où tu aimes en tout cas je te
remercie parce que tu m'a dit vas-y
vas-y vas-y épi parle un petit peu de ce
qu'il tient à coeur est une chose qui me
tient à coeur c'est les liens familiaux
ah bah ça y est on en arrive enfin en
famille aux biens familiaux
bah oui les parents les parents les
parents c c'est vraiment pour moi c'est
la clef de tout c'est la clé c'est la
basse et les racines vous savez les
racines des arbres qui sont là autour de
vous c'est eux qui vous inculque des
valeurs qui vous sont propres des
valeurs des valeurs familiales et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je voulais
vraiment vous parler de ça parce que ça
me tient beaucoup à coeur je sais que
c'est de là d'où on vient
alors une fois de plus on a tous des
points de vue différents là aujourd'hui
ce que je vous invite seulement à faire
c'est de m'écouter
merci mais également de construire votre
propre point de vue
c'est le mien n'est pas à généraliser
c'est simplement une expérience donc
voilà les parents les parents qui vous
inculque que ses valeurs alors des
parents il vous donne des bonnes choses
et des mauvaises choses oui évidemment
personne n'est parfait
trois bateaux il fait chier avec ses
phrases bateau et mais non non non
perfection c'est quoi la perfection on
en a une
chacun d'entre nous qui est différente
chacun notre vision de la perfection
puisqu'elle nous est propre en est
unique dans ce monde nous sommes tous
uniques
cette perfection elle vient de la part
de tout ce que vous avez pu apprendre
et justement pour en revenir encore aux
parents alors les mauvaises choses on va
y aller les mauvaises choses
pour ma part je pense que je suis un bon
grand et eu un bon grand têtu j'ai
toujours l'impression d'avoir raison
j'ai toujours l'impression d'avoir la
science exacte orji propos mais et oui
mais en fait c'est ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire avec ses points
d'amélioration comme on nous apprendra à
l'ieseg ces points ces points
d'amélioration c'est que vous ces
défauts vous pouvez les positives et
parce que ça vous apporte quelque chose
d'extraordinaire alors tu es tu sais
papa il a toujours raison et moi aussi
du coup mais du coup ça montre une
détermination sans faille
parce que quand vous êtes têtu vous
allez jusqu'au bout vous croyez en ce
que vous faites vous allez vraiment
jusqu'au bout et ça c'est pareil c'est
ensuite la sensibilité les sensibilités
j'ai tendance à me vexer un peu
facilement ça c'est vraiment parce que
maman elle emmagasine elle emmagasine
etc ou d'un moment là ça explose c'est
comme l'eponge salle et les plonge qui
sont les branches qui se remplit d'eau
ou d'un moment vous pouvez pu mettre
dosettes objet d un squeeze l'eponge et
puis enlever toute l'eau qui attend et
là c'est le coup de blues
le petit coup de blues sont répétitifs
qui sont chez moi perte de confiance en
soi
je pense qu'il y en a plein ici dans
cette salle qui ont déjà vécu ça j'ai de
mauvaises notes etc
et oui oui donc tout à fait fin cette
perte
de confiance en soi ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire c'est que si vous avez
la possibilité de penser remise en
question vous remettre en question parce
que quand on perd confiance en soi en
fait on essaie de comprendre pourquoi
les bains l'a voulu positiver parce que
vous prenez du recul
oum aziz m'écarte je regarde en large
comme je regarde là un peu demande est
là du coup vous prenez conscience de
choses très importantes
ce que vous avez une vision globale pour
terminer le perfectionnisme alors
certains d'entre vous dans la salle
diront d'infection nisme pour vraiment
un défaut mais aussi parce que c'est
assez embêtant le perfectionniste et
qu'on n'a jamais l'impression bien fini
le travail
par exemple moi j'en viens parfois quand
je fais un rapport de stage par exemple
si par exemple le numéro de page il en
gras moi je dis ah bah nan mais dans les
autres qui sont pas en grève mais en fin
de compte c'est un perfectionnisme ça
donne quoi ça donne aussi la
détermination parce que vous allez
jusqu'au bout des choses vous allez
toujours avoir des idées qui vont venir
au dernier moment vous allez avoir envie
de les appliquer etc
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire ce
défaut donc écouter voilà c'est déjà pas
mal pour les défauts un scan a déjà pas
mal je suis déjà bien confié maintenant
les bonnes choses parce que bon quand
même
il faut dire que vos parents normalement
ils vous inculque une des bonnes
choisissant vite vous éduquez celmo
l'éducation d'ailleurs on est même dans
une école en effet on fait de la nation
vous faut remettre les managers de
demain
mais oui mais c'est un élément clé au
final est par exemple un point positif
je peux dire que c'est ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure la détermination
enfin l'envi de envie d'entreprendre
l'envi de créer il envie d'innover
l'envi de faire différemment ça c'est
quelque chose que papa m'a donné sa la
détermination
demande en mariage 7,7 la huitième c'est
bon alors y'en a qui sont en train de se
dire lors attend cette femme et non
c'était la même
c'était la même et il ya à peu près un
mois et quelques jours de cela bas
c'était le mariage aux alentours de
leurs 60 ans c'est plutôt original
en plus de ça le fils de son père qui
est plutôt était son témoin holder ils
n'étaient pas baptisé hollande
ouf c'est tabou tout ça mais c'est ce
qui fait l'originalité de ce lien je
peux avoir avec mes parents alors on va
quand même faire qui pose là tous
ensemble parce que je pense qu'on en a
qui doivent se tenir ou pour l'heure à
temps là il en vient où la gerra qu'est
ce qu'il fait là
en plus de ça je suis pas moi mes
parents ils sont pop up store qu'est ce
qu'il veut dire par l'or etc
je répète bien c'est vraiment très
important que ce que je vous dis là
c'est une expérience qui est personnel
vous l'analysez vous la prenez comme
comme vous le souhaitez c'est vraiment
très important
alors j'espère vous en souviendrez bien
évidemment mais vous prenez vous prenez
pas dans tous les cas moi ça me fait
plaisir d'être là avec vous alors du
coup bon on va peut-être a essayé de se
dire trouver le nord alors justement ce
midi trouvé non ce qu'on va revenir
quand même au sujet de base trouvé la
mort quand j'ai dit ce midi on est en
train de déjeuner avec mes parents
et je vais vous dire quelque chose qui
était quand même là je demande vraiment
votre attention à toutes et tous mon
père y un moment au déjeuner ce midi
jeudi boba le terme c'est le thème
pardon s'est trouvée nord pas encore
trouvé
et là il dit ah si en fait je crois que
les trouver cette amère et ça et ce à
quelques pas c'est quelque chose de oui
c'est facile et ça bouillonne un peu
plein je vous dirais que j'ai appelé
motifs donc je vais essayer de contrôler
un peu mes émotions se soit enfin voilà
trouver nord en fait c'est aussi par
rapport
comme je vous le disais aux racines et
aux envies de vos parents ce qu'ils
aiment faire parce qu'en fin de compte
aujourd'hui touche ici dans la salle je
vois qu'il ya pas que des étudiants
il ya aussi des personnes qui sont en
entreprise et peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
ces personnes là l envie quitter leur
entreprise parce que ça se passe mal
ou peut-être qu'ils sont en phase de
divorce j'en sais rien je connais pas du
tout la situation dans laquelle vous
êtes tous ici dans la salle
mais dans tous les cas dans tous les cas
ce qui est important à se souvenir c'est
que ça vient tout ça des racines ce que
vous avez envie de faire et ce que vous
avez envie de faire ça vient aussi de ce
qu'aime faire vos parents par exemple la
mer c'est la cuisine pour capter porte
de la cuisine a peut-être un petit peu
de pierre je ne sais pas mais voilà
c'est c'est fou et essai faire des
blancs en neige ferme ont souhaité vous
l'interprétez comme vous voulez
évidemment vous l'interprétez vous voilà
vous mixez des ingrédients vous faites
vous donner du plaisir nous donner du
plaisir aux autres
vous faites le moelleux au chocolat le
moelleux au chocolat vous savez celui
qui est dans le four là comme ça vous
ouvrez
porte du four vous prenez un nuage de
fumée but est un peu faussé un peu cramé
quoi et puis vous à moi qui ai des
lunettes en plus je ne vois rien du tout
mais par contre est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est qu'à ce moment là
vous avez l'auteur du chocolat au lait
le chocolat il est peut on encore dans
votre bouche que vous l'avez déjà là là
ça frétille arrive à tous les sens qui
sont qui sont en éveil
vous avez même peut-être un peu de
frisson pour ceux qui adorent vraiment
le chocolat et voilà il faut attendre un
peu parce qu'il est encore chaud mais
bon c'est vrai qu'avec une petite crème
anglaise et puis une petite boule de
glace à la vanille c'est plutôt
sympathique
donc voilà ma passion pour la cuisine
elle vient de ma mère et c'est pour ça
que je veux faire de la restauration
plus tard c'est aussi simple que ça
c'est pour ça que c'est ce que j'ai
envie de faire j'adore voir les gens au
restaurant manger quand par exemple
alors on se prend une situation tous
ensemble vous prenez un peu ce que vous
voulez mais ya deux personnes un coucou
je sais pas des gens qui viennent de se
rencontrer ce que vous voulez ok donc il
ya deux personnes
et là il ya deux associés de karim c'est
pareil ce qu'attend en fonction de vos
goûts vous mettez tout ce que vous
voulez moi je ferai un petit gratin
dauphinois avec une bonne entrecôte
saignante parce que je les aime bien
puis un petit peu de sauce au poivre
simple mais ça tient bien au corps et
ben justement cette entrecôte la save et
le le client il la coupe là il prend la
première bouchée et là ça fait est là il
coupe mais il va d'arrache-pied le
gratin dauphinois la salade et tout ça
pouf et là ça va hyper vite et en fait
c'est son sourire qui est extraordinaire
il est content d'être là ils partagent
un moment avec une personne grâce à la
nourriture et ça procure du bien-être je
trouve que c'est extraordinaire comme
métier ensuite papa donc ça c'est recul
2 m'entendez magnifique donc on en était
du coup à 2,3 papa merci c'est gentil
papa c'est l'entrepreneuriat pop à hilla
il a créé son entreprise
le petit fils à papa qui a créé son
entreprise non mais non rien à voir ce
qu'on veut créer une entreprise c'est
que vous avez envie d'entreprendre de
créer d'innover c'est ce que je vous
disais au début c'est ça qui vous donne
envie
alors oui il ya aussi le fait d'avoir
envie d'avoir son nom peut-être aussi
placardé quelques pas d'être président
directeur général d'une entreprise il ya
peut-être tout ça mais en fin de compte
c'est pareil c'est pas avoir la grosse
tête
bah non parce que ça ça vient d'où si
vous avez eu envie d'entreprendre est
créé à ce moment là avec une idée que
vous avez c'est parce que celle ci est
venue d'expérience que vous avez eue
avec des gens c'est ces gens là qui vous
ont procuré ça ils vous ont donnés ils
vous ont donnés donner quelque chose
vous ont donné envie d'entreprendre est
donnée d'aller à l'endroit où vous
souhaitiez donc voilà écoutez je pense
que on a déjà pas mal faire le tour par
rapport à tout ça alors maintenant je
vais passer à la séquence émotion parce
que ça donne toujours envie à tout le
monde et moi ça me faire du bien parce
que en plus je vais dire quelque chose
que je dis pas forcément et que vous
vous dites assez rarement je pense à vos
parents quelque chose qu'on devrait dire
plus souvent que papa maman je vous aime
au plus profond de moi même et que vous
êtes des gens formidables des gens
formidables je pèse mes mots parce que
parce que vous êtes un appui permanent
pour moi vous êtes toujours là à
n'importe quelle heure du jour ou de la
nuit
et ça c'est extraordinaire c'est à dire
que c'est une confiance
incassable je peux vous dire tout tout
ce qu'il ya de bien ou de ce qu'il ya de
mauvais dans ce que j'ai fait parce
qu'on fait pas tous des trucs très bien
dans la vie eh ben notre conscience elle
est toujours là et c'est un amour
incassable un amour éternel
et ça je pense que
même si je sais qu'ici dans la salle il
ya des personnes qui n'ont pas forcément
cette relation avec leurs parents
peut-être que c'est des gens qui ont des
parents qui sont peut-être divorce et
des parentes sont peut-être décédé
ou alors des parents avec qui ils ont
des problèmes de communication quoi que
ce soit peu importe peu importe si vous
êtes là aujourd'hui c'est grâce à eux
sans que vous ne seriez pas là ils ont
donné pour vous soyez là vous rendez
compte de cela c'est la procréation
or il y en a qui rigole assez marrant
parce que du coup vous hanter peut-être
un peu gêné mais mais c'est la clé ils
vous ont donné la vie vous ne seriez pas
là aujourd'hui et ça faut en avoir
conscience de ça de ses racines
parce que là c'est vos racines vos
parents parce qu'ils vous ont créé mais
plus tard vous serez sûrement les rats
sont d'autres personnes
et c'est ça qui est magnifique dans la
procréation
vous allez en tout cas je l'espère pour
beaucoup d'entre vous avoir des enfants
et les aimer au plus profond de votre
coeur et j'espère très sincèrement que
qu'il ya trois mots que vous allez donc
vous allez vous souvenir
alors ces trois mots c'est donner pour
recevoir
ça il nous reçoit encore ces trucs
bateau mais non non parce que donner
pour recevoir
c'est pas forcément matériel ça peut
être de l'expérience du vécu
il faut savoir également recevoir pour
donner c'est dans les deux sens que ça
fonctionne c'est du vécu c'est pas je ne
sais pas par exemple quand on pense à
donner pour recevoir des fois on peut se
dire houba houba voilà le spot là il m'a
permis d'avoir ce job là donc du coup je
vais lui offrir une bouteille de
champagne
oui mais non mais non c'est pas de ça
dont je vous parle ces mêmes les
expériences négatives que vous avez pu
avoir avec des gens qui vous ont alerté
qui vous ont permis de vous dire que ça
vous ne le referais pas ils vous ont
donnés par quelques moyens que ce soit
ils vous ont donné il faut savoir le
recevoir le partage
l'ouverture d'esprit l'ouverture aux
autres c'est très important parce que ça
vous enrichit c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'extraordinaire
alors là ce soir par exemple qu'est ce
que vous me donnez
j'aime bien quand vous me regardez vous
m'écoutez voilà vous me donner de l'
écoute pour ceux qui se sentent
peut-être un peu plus gêné qui tourne la
tête vers leurs voisins et qui me
regardent pas dans les yeux
peu importe vous êtes également présents
ici et ça c'est ce que vous me donnez
qui que vous soyez que je vous connais
ce que je veux que je ne vous
connaissent pas vous me donnez l'honneur
de votre présence vraiment je le pense
sincèrement c'est du brut que je vous
dis là c'était même pas prévu dans mon
texte de base donc je le ressens là avec
mes tripes là ici là bon je pense qu'on
a déjà bien fait le tour moi j'ai passé
un très bon moment avec vous j'espère
que vous recevrez quelque chose ce soir
avec vous en souviendrez donner pour
recevoir
par pitié et en toute humilité s'il vous
plaît donnez pour recevoir commencé
aussi bien le faire dans ce beau nord de
la france merci beaucoup